An efficient cache aware matrix multiply
performs a sequence of of submatrix or
block by block multiplies.
You choose the block size so that,
nominally, three blocks fit in cache.
The corresponding algorithm looks like
this, and notice that the block size is
denoted by little b appears
directly in the algorithm.
Now you can show that the number of
cache misses is asymptotically n cubed
divided by L times b.
And since b is proportional
to square root of Z,
that's just n cubed over L root z.
As it happens, for
any non-Strassen matrix multiply,
no algorithm can do
asymptotically better than this.
Now, since b is a function
of the cache size, and
it appears in the algorithm,
we say this algorithm is cache-aware.
Here's a question for you.
Is there a different algorithm
that dos not refer to L or Z, yet
somehow still attains the lower bound?
The answer is yes.
It's based on the the idea of divide and
conquer.
Let's assume for simplicity,
that the matrices are n by n,
where n is an integer power of two.
The algorithm first partitions the
matrices into two by two submatrices.
Then performs eight recursive
matrix multiplies to update
the two by two C block.
To be more precise,
here's the pseudocode algorithm.
The base case occurs when A,
B and C are scalars.
The algorithm just
performs a scalar update.
Otherwise, the input matrices are
logically partitioned into quadrants as
shown in the figure.
The algorithm performs eight
recursive matrix multiplies to
update the four quadrants of C.
Now as a pseudo code reveals,
this algorithm is cache oblivious.
Unlike the block algorithm, it makes no
reference to the size of the cache, or
of the line size.
Now we need to analyze this algorithm
Let's forget about cache misses for
the moment and suppose you just wanted
to count the number of adds and
multiplies.
How would you do it?
Well the algorithm's recursive so
you'd write down a recurrence
relation maybe like this one.
The first case counts
the eight recursive calls
on half the problem size.
The base case counts the multiplies and
adds or flops and namely there are two.
If you solve this recurrence exactly
you would get 2 n cubed flops which is
exactly what you would expect.
Now, what about cache misses?
Imagine the recursion tree.
Each node is a function call.
There's eight way
branching at each node,
and the leaves correspond
to the base case.
And of course the problem size shrinks
progressively from n down to one.
At some point in this recursion, all
the operands of a subtree fit in cache.
Let's say that level is little l,
and call that size n sub l.
At that point, it must be that
three blocks fit in cache.
If the matrix is stored in row or
column major layout, then you'd
also need to assume tall caches.
Then you can conclude that n
sub l will be less than or
equal to some constant fraction of z.
I'll denote that fraction by
the fudge constant f for the moment.
So a recurrence for
the cache misses will have two cases.
The first is when
the operands fit in cache.
The number of cache misses
is just proportional to
n sub L squared divided by L.
That's the base case.
Otherwise, there's the recursive case.
You pay for misses at each of
the eight branches plus, let's assume,
a constant number within
the function call itself.
If you solve this recurrence,
you should get the following,
n cubed over L root z.
This matches the cache aware algorithm,
as well as the lower bound, yet
remember that the algorithm
itself never refers to z or L.
That's oblivious, baby!